la délégation du conseil général de la
réunion dans les salons de boffrand à la
présidence du sénat le lieu est
prestigieux le prix également les rubans
du développement durable depuis dix ans
l'initiative lancée notamment par
l'association des maires de france
récompense des collectivités locales
pour leur engagement cette année le
département de la réunion a été choisi
comme une dizaine d'autres collectivités
une reconnaissance nationale pour les
actions de développement durable dans
chacune des politiques du conseil
général les rubans du développement
durable est un prix
nationalement connus et qui est donnée
par un jury autonome le président est un
philosophe et donc je crois que c'est
une récompense qui au fond doit être
dédiée à l'ensemble bien évidemment des
agents qui ont travaillé au niveau du
conseil général mais j'ai envie de dire
c'est le prix de chaque réunionnais je
dédie donc ce prix à tous les
réunionnais parce que nous sommes un
petit département
l'éducation à la culture
environnementale à la culture écologique
et capital faut que nous préservions et
nous valorisons ce beau patrimoine qui
est le note qui est aujourd'hui classée
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco la
majorité de ces jeunes nous les avons
mis sur des chantiers d'insertion en les
mettant en activité pour travailler dans
les eaux de les préserver l'existant
alors mieux qu'un discours je vous
invite tous vraiment à venir voir qu'est
ce que c'est que la durabilité chez nous
à l'île de la réunion une invitation au
voyage largement applaudi parmi les
invités au sénat qui ont accueilli avec
de larges sourires la présentation faite
par la délégation réunionnaise dans la
candidature le département a mis en
avant les efforts portés sur le jardin
de l'état ceux des agriculteurs avec la
diversification des cultures l'artisanat
avec la filière bois de goyavier et tous
les projets en faveur des eaux protéger
le patrimoine naturel en favorisant
l'insertion c'est l'un des aspects qui a
séduit le jury des actions à l'échelle
locale elles sont quasiment pratiquement
les seuls aujourd'hui
qu'ils prennent vraiment au sérieux
certains aspects de ce qu'on appelle la
durabilité pour la réunion c'est
l'histoire des sentiers et puis si vous
voulez le maillage environnement social
nouzha groupes intéressés oui ces
collectivités sont attentives aux enjeux
du monde au compteur contemporain oui
elles sont réactives aux attentes
nouvelles de leurs concitoyens le
président du sénat jean-pierre bel a
rappelé le rôle fondamental des
collectivités locales une politique sur
le long terme pour le conseil général de
la réunion avec les rubans du
développement durable c'est le troisième
prix que reçoit le département pour son
action dans le domaine